Irgendwo im Tian-Shan-Gebirge,
im Nordwesten von China.
Das base camp der Expedition
des Schweizerischen Alpenclubs
im Dauerregen.
Stimmt! Es war die kälteste Nacht,
aber mir war mega warm.
Normalerweise mache ich
den Schlafsack ganz zu.
Ich hatte ihn halb offen.
Fünf junge Bergsteiger
und ihr lead guide warten drauf,
dass die Wolken sich lichten
und sie endlich den Berg ihrer Träume
besteigen können.
Ein Monat früher.
Die Abenteurer absolvieren einen
PR-Termin bei einem ihrer Ausrüster.
Lachen!
Sie müssen sich
erst noch daran gewöhnen,
im Zentrum der Aufmerksamkeit
zu stehen.
Gut, danke!
Allez!
Zwei Jahre lang haben sie sich
auf diese Mission vorbereitet.
Sie erlernten
spezielle Klettertechniken.
Attaque, attaque, attaque!
Sie übten
die Rettung am Berg in Gebieten,
die für die Rega
nicht erreichbar sind.
Sie wurden
zu einem eingeschworenen Team,
bereit für das grosse Abenteuer.
Auf der Expedition werden wir
in unbekanntem Gelände sein.
Es wird kein Kletterbüchlein geben,
das hilft.
Man muss also schnell lernen
und sich anpassen.
Man muss Ideen haben und manchmal
auch unkonventionell handeln.
Das ist eine wichtige Fähigkeit.
Sie alle
sind herausragende Bergsteiger.
Und sie verfolgen ihren Traum
mit Leidenschaft.
Lukas Hinterberger aus Gais
ist 22 Jahre alt.
Er finanziert sich die Bergsteigerei,
indem er Teilzeit
in der elterlichen Käserei arbeitet.
Bergsteigen ist für mich mehr als
ein Sport, es ist eine Leidenschaft.
Ich arbeite in erster Linie,
um Geld zu verdienen.
Und ich denke auch,
gar nicht arbeiten
funktioniert finanziell nicht
und ist auch für die Psyche
nicht so gut.
Wenn ich drei, vier, fünf Tage
wieder arbeite,
bin ich danach sehr motiviert,
wieder in die Berge zu gehen.
Der Chemielaborant Sebastian Briw
aus Naters, 21,
steckt mitten in der Ausbildung
zum Bergführer.
Ich investiere dafür
eigentlich die ganze Zeit,
die ich zur Verfügung habe.
Im Winter Ski fahren,
Skitouren oder Eisklettern.
Im Sommer ist es Klettern,
Bergsteigen.
Ich versuche, jede freie Minute
damit zu verbringen.
Roman von Schulthess, aus St. Gallen
und ebenfalls 21 Jahre alt,
arbeitet Teilzeit als Schreiner.
Hier zu arbeiten,
ist für mich natürlich super,
weil der eine Chef
ein guter Kletterkollege ist.
Sie haben hier sehr viel Verständnis
für meine Prioritäten.
Es macht hier sehr viel Spass,
aber es geht auch etwas darum,
Geld zu verdienen.
Der 21-jährige Sebastien Monney
lebt bei seinen Eltern in Fribourg
und will nach der Expedition die
Ausbildung zum Bergführer beginnen.
Als Bergsteiger
würde ich gerne reisen.
Ich möchte auf Berge
in Indien und Südamerika.
Da, wo man noch
ein bisschen überlegen muss.
Dort ist es nicht wie in Chamonix,
wo alle Routen schon gemacht sind.
Nicolas Hojac schliesslich,
mit 23 Jahren der Älteste im Team,
studiert Maschinenbau
und wohnt bei seinen Eltern
in Niederscherli bei Bern.
Es sind alle mega motiviert,
jeder hat für sich trainiert.
Weil wir
aus der ganzen Schweiz kommen,
können wir
nicht immer gemeinsam trainieren.
Man hat letzte Woche gesehen,
als wir im Südtirol unterwegs waren:
Alle sind mega fit und motiviert
und wir freuen uns sehr,
dorthin zu gehen und hoffentlich
etwas Schlaues zu machen
und nicht irgendwie vom Wetter her
eingeschränkt zu werden.
Das Hochgebirge Tian Shan
im Grenzgebiet zu Kasachstan
ist berüchtigt
für sein launisches Wetter.
Aber die wilde Gegend
bietet dem Team das,
was es in der Schweiz
nicht finden kann:
unbestiegene Gipfel
auf über 6'500 m Höhe.
Hast du es?
Ein paar Tage vor der Abreise.
Das Expeditionsteam
sucht die Ausrüstung zusammen,
die aus dem Fundus des Schweizerisch-
en Alpenclubs mit nach China soll.
Das ist von denen.
Auch egal. Ich ziehe.
Lead guide Denis Burdet gehört zu
den besten Bergsteigern der Schweiz.
Er war schon
auf der ganzen Welt unterwegs
und hat mit dem Team
für die Expedition trainiert.
Wir machen einen Igel,
5-m-Stücke.
Ja, unterschiedlich.
Die Schweizerische Gesellschaft
für Gebirgsmedizin
stellt der Expedition
zwei Ärzte zur Seite.
Roman Hari und Nora Bienz
sind am Packtag
ebenfalls nach Bern gekommen,
um die medizinische Versorgung
abschliessend zu planen.
SAC-Ausbildungsleiter Bruno Hasler
bespricht mit dem Team
die letzten Details der Expedition.
Hier habe ich noch eine Erklärung,
dass ihr auf eigenes Risiko geht.
Denis und ich tun natürlich alles,
damit nichts passiert.
Auch die Ärzte arbeiten
nach bestem Wissen und Gewissen.
Aber für alles,
was nicht gesetzlich vorgegeben ist,
muss man eine Haftausschluss-
erklärung unterzeichnen.
Ihr seid also
völlig auf euch allein gestellt.
Das ist etwas heikler,
dafür hat es nicht so viele Leute in
dieser Gegend. Das ist auch schön.
Wir haben wirklich alles gegeben,
um Sauerstoff zu organisieren.
Für China ist es einfach
ganz, ganz schwierig.
Irgendwann ist es ganz klar
auch eine Kostenfrage.
Aber es ist v.a.
ein logistisches Problem.
Das andere ist die Luftrettung:
In China gibt es keine Luftrettung
vor Ort. Das gibt es einfach nicht.
Wenn irgendetwas ist,
muss man mit den vorhandenen Mitteln
einen Abtransport machen bis dort,
wo der Rega-Jet einfliegen könnte.
Das klären wir noch ab.
In einem Land in Südamerika
wäre es viel einfacher,
über das Internet herauszufinden,
was es dort gibt,
wie die Infrastruktur vor Ort ist.
China ist halt
immer noch sehr abgeschottet.
Nach zwei Jahren Vorbereitung
ist der Tag der Abreise gekommen.
Trotz der Vorfreude fällt
der Abschied nicht allen leicht.
Schlussendlich
sind sie doch fast allein am Berg.
Sei es Steinschlag, Lawinen -
die Gefahren sind einfach da.
Die ist auch in der Schweiz da,
wenn sie bergsteigen gehen.
Aber in der Schweiz gibt es die Rega
und dort sind sie abgelegen
und es gibt das alles gar nicht so.
Ich bin sehr dankbar und froh,
wenn er gesund zurückkommt.
Aber er kann
mit dem Auto arbeiten gehen -
und auch dort
kann ihm etwas passieren.
Ich darf keine Angst haben.
Das geht nicht.
Da würde man wahrscheinlich krank,
wenn man immer in Angst leben würde.
Ich bin einfach sehr glücklich, dass
er seine Leidenschaft ausleben kann.
Zu sehen, dass es ihm gut geht.
Er hat einen Traum,
den er schon als Jugendlicher hatte,
er hat für diesen Traum gekämpft,
und es funktioniert.
Für Eltern gibt es ehrlich gesagt
nichts Schöneres.
Das ist wirklich aussergewöhnlich,
dass er seiner Leidenschaft
folgen kann.
Es ist nicht selbstverständlich,
seinen Traum zu leben.
Er hat die Möglichkeit.
Ich hoffe,
er kann sie noch lange nutzen.
Bist du stolz?
- Aber ja!
Das Team fliegt zuerst nach Istanbul.
Nach einem kurzen Zwischenhalt geht
es weiter nach Almaty in Kasachstan
und schliesslich nach Ürümqi
im Nordwesten Chinas.
Ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen,
was da alles passieren kann.
Und das ist auch gut so.
Auf eine Art bin ich froh,
dass kein Kontakt da ist.
Denn ich kann eh nichts tun.
Zu wissen, dass dort etwas passiert,
aber ich hier gebunden bin,
wäre noch viel schlimmer.
Wenn ich ihn sehe, wenn er irgendwo
war und wieder nach Hause kommt
und er so strahlt, denke ich:
Was will ich als Mutter mehr?
Dass er glücklich ist.
Und das ist er.
Uah!
1.30 Uhr in der Früh.
Nach 30 Std. Reise
wartet das Expeditionsteam
im Flughafen von Ürümqi auf David,
den chinesischen Kontaktmann.
Sebastien, der
die Details der Reise geplant hat,
fühlt sich verantwortlich
für den reibungslosen Ablauf.
Scheisse, das ist alles chinesisch.
Ich probiere,
über WiFi ins Internet zu kommen,
um David zu finden,
denn er ist nicht da.
Er sollte hier auf uns warten,
ist aber nicht hier.
Excuse me! I got a question.
Gibt es hier WLAN?
Thank you! Thank you very much!
Offenbar geht es leichter,
wenn das ein Chinese macht.
Mal schauen, ob es klappt.
C'est Scheissdreck!
* Husten *
Eine Stunde später
taucht David dann doch noch auf.
* Erleichterte Rufe *
Hello!
Tut mir leid, da hat es
ein Missverständnis gegeben
wegen der Zeit.
- Yes, no problem.
David ist für die Expedition
der entscheidende Mann in China.
Ein halbes Jahr lang
hat Sebastien mit ihm
die Einzelheiten der Expedition
besprochen,
unzählige Mails getauscht
und mögliche Stolpersteine
aus dem Weg geräumt.
Kurz vor Tagesanbruch erreichen sie
endlich ihre Unterkunft -
eine Jugendherberge
im Zentrum der Stadt.
(Sebastien) Alles da.
(Denis) Ein kleines Bier
vor dem Schlafengehen?
Oh ja!
- Ja!
Wir nehmen doch noch ein Bier.
(Denis)
Wir putzen die Zähne mit Bier.
Das klingt gut.
- "Spling", ja, genau.
Mh, gut!
- Quöllfrisch!
Ürümqi, die Hauptstadt
der autonomen Provinz Xinjiang.
Zwei Tage haben die Schweizer Zeit,
um letzte Vorbereitungen zu treffen.
Die erste Begegnung
mit dem Verbindungsoffizier
der chinesischen Regierung steht an.
Er wird die Expedition
auf Schritt und Tritt begleiten.
Hello!
-  Hello.
My english ...
* Sie spricht chinesisch. *
Der gefürchtete Aufpasser
heisst Ao Lei,
ist eine Frau
und leutseliger als erwartet.
Sie hat sich gut vorbereitet.
Sämtliche Bewilligungen
für das Klettern im Tian-Shan-Gebirge
liegen bereits auf dem Tisch.
Ao Lei ist selbst Bergsteigerin
und kennt sich
mit der chinesischen Bürokratie aus.
* Sie liest auf Chinesisch vor. *
Und sie hat ganz und gar nicht vor,
die Anstandsdame für die Regierung
zu spielen.
* Fernöstlich anmutende Zupfklänge *
Denis und Sebastien fahren mit Ao Lei
zum Bergsteigerverband
der autonomen Provinz Xinjiang.
Die Organisation will den Schweizern
Material zur Verfügung stellen,
v.a. ein grosses Küchenzelt,
das noch aus der Zeit der
Kulturrevolution zu stammen scheint.
Wir sind gerade dabei,
zu prüfen, ob alles dabei ist.
Das ist vermutlich das Essenszelt.
Wir haben hier
die extraleichten Heringe.
Und auch die anderen Sachen
sind superleicht.
Das Zelt muss um die 50 kg
schwer sein mit den Stangen.
(Sebastien) Ich muss zahlen.
In einem Hinterzimmer
ihrer Unterkunft hat Sebastien
ein Treffen mit dem Kontaktmann
der Expedition vereinbart.
David hat bereits mehrmals
eine ausländische Expedition
ins Tian-Shan-Gebirge geführt.
Five, six, seven, eight,
nine, ten, eleven ...
20'000 $ wechseln die Hand.
Ein Vermögen.
Okay, jetzt hab ich alles Geld.
Damit gibt es für euch
keine Probleme mehr.
Yes, okay, tipptopp.
- Okay.
Thank you.
- Auf eine gute Zusammenarbeit!
Das hier ist alles für die Reise.
Alles wird damit bezahlt.
Die Bewilligungen,
unser Essen, alles.
Yes, okay, tipptopp. Thank you.
- Right?
Das wird schon klappen.
Er hat
schon fünf Expeditionen begleitet.
Wir hatten Kontakt
mit dem Leiter einer Expedition,
die ihn engagiert hatte. Er hat
gesagt, das sei ein guter Typ.
Ich denke also nicht, dass er nun
mit unserer Kohle abhaut.
Der Rest des Teams
besorgt sich unterdessen Proviant
für die Busreise,
die sie zum Ausgangspunkt
ihrer Expedition bringen wird.
Bouillon, Suppe, Milchpulver, Tee.
Tee.
Tee ist sicher auch hier, nicht?
- Tee ist woanders.
Peppermint.
Hey, Ricola, Mann, voll geil!
Wollen wir Ricola?
Wollen wir?
- Nein.
La cannella.
Getrockneter Fusspilz.
- Das ist sicher nicht gesund.
Speziell eklig.
Keine Ahnung, was es genau ist.
Das kaufen wir nicht ein
zum Mitnehmen.
Im Moment
habe ich nicht so viele Gefühle.
Ich freue mich darauf,
diese Stadt zu verlassen.
Es hat hier mega viele Leute
uns stinkt mega. Aber ...
... als Landei ist man sich halt
so grosse Städte nicht so gewohnt.
Es sind sicher alle froh, dass wir
jetzt raus können Richtung Berge.
* Wild-West-Musik *
In drei Tagen will das Team
von Ürümqi nach Xiate reisen,
dem letzten Vorposten
der Zivilisation
vor dem Tian-Shan-Gebirge.
Wie in ganz China
ist auch in Xinjiang
der Bauboom ein sichtbares Zeichen
einer stark wachsenden Wirtschaft.
(Alle) Ja!
Zwischenhalt in Ili.
Roman Hari inspiziert
das lokale Angebot an Medikamenten.
Als Mitglied der Schweizerischen
Gesellschaft für Gebirgsmedizin
ist der Arzt für die medizinische
Versorgung der Expedition zuständig.
Das muss einem schon bewusst sein:
Es sind hier ca. zweieinhalb Tage
bis in ein Spital.
Wenn man einen Unfall hat ...
Vom base camp aus ist es
wahrscheinlich gut ein Tag
bis anderthalb,
wenn man jemanden tragen müsste.
Dann sind es
noch mal sechs, sieben, acht Stunden
über eine nicht sehr gute Strasse
bis nach Ili.
Hier wären wir an einem Ort
mit einer guten Versorgung.
Aber zweieinhalb Tage
sind natürlich sehr lang,
wenn man einen Schwerverletzten hat.
Eine Helikopterrettung
ist nicht realistisch.
Es gäbe wahrscheinlich schon Helis,
v.a. vom Militär,
aber die bekommt man einfach nicht.
Kirgistan wäre eine Möglichkeit.
Dort gibt es
eine Art Rettung mit Helis,
aber die dürfen natürlich
hier in China nicht fliegen.
Deshalb wäre der Transport
zuerst anderthalb Tage zu Fuss
und dann mit einem Jeep oder der
Ambulanz - falls es funktioniert -
nach Ili.
Das wäre die Evakuationsmöglichkeit.
Der Bus bewegt sich zermürbend
langsam durch die Landschaft.
Immer weiter
dringt die Reisegesellschaft
in den wilden Westen Chinas vor.
Nach drei Tagen Fahrt
und ein paar Hindernissen
erreicht das Team endlich
das Tor zum Nationalpark
vor dem Tian-Shan-Gebirge.
* Majestätische Blasmusik *
Das wurde langsam Zeit!
Jetzt sind wir genug gereist.
Wir waren jetzt alle froh,
wieder ein paar
schneebedeckte Gipfel zu sehen.
Wahrscheinlich geht es jetzt
immer noch mind. zwei Tage,
bis wir dort sind.
Wir haben sie gesehen,
aber dort sind wir noch lange nicht.
Aber jetzt kann man langsam erahnen,
wofür wir überhaupt hier sind.
* Treibender Dance-Song:
"Sonnentanz" von Klangkarussel *
* Hupen *
* Die Musik verklingt. *
Hot Springs, der letzte bewohnte
Flecken vor der grossen Wildnis.
Noch sind ein paar Missverständnisse
aus dem Weg zu räumen.
Du kaufst mehr Brot.
Du bezahlst für das Frühstück
und fürs Mittag- und Abendessen.
Weisst du, es war völlig okay,
dass wir in der Stadt
für das Essen gesorgt haben.
Von hier an ist es aber
dein Teil der Organisation.
Ja, klar!
- Du hast hier Essen gekauft?
Keine Sorge. Alles ist bereit.
Das ist meine Frage.
Das Essen ist hier?
Alles ist hier.
Und tatsächlich:
Du musst jetzt eben
keine Angst haben.
Du musst sicher nicht hungern.
Lieber erschlagen.
Damit hätte ich weniger Mühe.
Aber einfach so in den Hals
schneiden, finde ich mega ...
Reicht das?
Frische Schafsleber
gibt es heute zum Abendessen.
Der Besitzer der Jurte
ist persönlich darum besorgt,
dass den Schweizern
während der Nacht warm ist.
Vielleicht ist er schon unten,
wenn wir um ...
Ja, man weiss nie!
Wenn du ein wenig rechts
von dieser Schulter bist ...
Think positive!
Oder hier durch.
- Ich weiss nicht.
Das Ziel rückt näher.
Noch einmal besprechen die Jungs
ihre Pläne, die bevorzugten Routen,
die Berge, die sie erklimmen wollen.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
* Krähen *
* Chinesische Zurufe *
Der Treck,
der die Lasten ins base camp
im Tian-Shan-Gebirge
transportieren wird,
setzt sich aus 22 Pferden und einem
halben Dutzend Reitern zusammen.
Heute werden wir unser ganzes Gepäck
auf die Pferde verladen.
Dann werden wir
in dieses Tal hier hinten gehen.
Sie haben uns gesagt, wir werden
heute ca. 7 Std. unterwegs sein.
Dann werden wir dort campieren.
Wir haben Schlafsack und Zelt dabei.
In dieser Nacht
haben wir in einer Jurte geschlafen,
aber diesen Luxus
haben wir nachher nicht mehr.
Morgen werden wir dann
ins base camp kommen,
was noch einmal
ca. 5 Std. dauern wird.
* Spannungsgeladene Trommelmusik *
* Wiehern *
* Erhabene Klänge *
* Jauchzen *
Das ist verdammt kalt.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Kalt, nass.
Aber es geht.
Jetzt haben wir schon
den Pass erreicht.
Es geht jetzt langsam abwärts
in Richtung base camp.
Jetzt sieht man auch zum ersten Mal
den Xuelian Feng West.
Sieht imposant aus.
* Majestätische Musik *
Hier, auf 3'500 m ü.M.,
werden die Bergsteiger
für die nächsten drei Wochen leben
und von hier aus
ihre Touren ins Gebirge unternehmen.
Ja, es ist schon ein Traumland.
Aber wir sind noch
mega weit weg von den Bergen.
Ein rund 2 km breiter,
zerklüfteter Gletscher
trennt das base camp
vom Xuelian Feng,
dem eigentlichen Ziel
ihrer Expedition.
Dort gibt es weder Vegetation
noch frisches Wasser.
Deshalb bauen sie das Camp
auf diesem Flecken Grasland
mit einem nahe gelegenen Fluss auf.
Eine kleine Oase inmitten
der unwirtlichen Steinlandschaft.
So!
Aber der Wind zieht so.
- Seitenwind ist scheisse, nicht?
So stark wird er nicht sein.
Denis, jetzt habt ihr
in jede Richtung mal gezeigt.
So?
* Rasanter Indie-Song: "First
Push" von DeVotchKa & Mychael Danna *
Noch ein Erinnerungsfoto,
dann machen sich die Reiter
auf den weiten Weg
zurück nach Hot Springs.
Mit schlechtem Wetter haben
die Schweizer Bergsteiger gerechnet.
Aber dass es mitten im Juli schneit,
ist dann doch eine Überraschung.
Das braucht noch einen Tag,
bis es trocken ist.
Oh la la!
Hey!
Ich bin unbewaffnet!
Das Wetter ist wechselhaft, aber
das spielt noch nicht so eine Rolle.
Lieber jetzt etwas schlechteres,
durchzogenes Wetter
als jetzt perfektes Wetter
und kaum sind wir akklimatisiert,
schlechtes Wetter.
Das würde mich mehr ärgern.
Das Satellitentelefon ist die
einzige Verbindung zur Aussenwelt.
Es dient v.a. dazu, per Textnachricht
die Wetterprognose zu erhalten.
Auf 5'000 m oft Regen, Regenschauer,
ab 4'700 m Schnee.
Aber das, was ich gerade
gelesen habe, war ganz anders.
(Lukas) Das stimmt eh nicht.
Er hat es wohl abgeschickt,
bevor wir unseres geschickt haben.
Jetzt kreuzen sie sich.
Der hochsommerliche Wintereinbruch
dauert mehrere Tage.
Dann klart es auf
und das Tian-Shan-Gebirge
präsentiert sich in seiner ganzen
majestätischen Schönheit.
Die Schweizer wollen sich mit einer
mehrtägigen Akklimatisationstour
auf die Höhe vorbereiten,
die sie später beim Aufstieg
zum 6'500 m hohen Expeditionsziel
Xuelian Feng überwinden müssen.
Sexy, was?
Roman Hari, Höhenmediziner und selbst
leidenschaftlicher Bergsteiger,
will dabei überprüfen,
wie die Teilnehmer
auf die ungewohnte Höhe reagieren.
Man merkt, dass bei den Jungen
der Drive, schneller hochzugehen,
grösser ist.
Es ist etwas vom Schwierigsten
für sie,
die alle
so dermassen fit und bereit sind,
zu lernen, dass es in der Höhe
je langsamer desto besser ist.
Auch wenn man beim Hochgehen
500 Höhenmeter pro Stunde
schaffen würde,
sollte man mit 250 gehen.
Das ist für die Akklimatisation
viel besser.
Deadman Peak.
So hat das Team
den noch unbestiegenen Gipfel
respektvoll getauft.
Damit ihre Körper
genügend Zeit haben,
sich auf die Höhe einzustellen,
wollen sie den Berg
in mehreren Etappen bezwingen.
Nach einer ersten Nacht im Biwak
werden sie wieder
ins base camp zurückkehren.
Am späten Nachmittag erreicht
das Team den ersten Biwak-Platz.
In aller Eile
bauen die Jungs ihre Zelte auf.
Das wird eine sog. Schlafplattform
für unser Zelt.
Wir müssen uns beeilen,
denn es kommt wieder ein Sturm.
Wie jeden Abend.
Bist du drin?
Es ist schönes Wetter.
Aber hier drin
haben wir ein schönes Cheminee.
Jetzt gibt es ein leckeres Gulasch.
Mmh!
Mamas Gulasch!
- Gulasch aus Ungarn!
* Feine Streicher-
und Gitarrenmusik *
Das Wetter im Tian-Shan-Gebirge
ist launenhaft.
Gegen Abend
scheint bereits wieder die Sonne,
und das Team ändert
für den nächsten Tag den Plan.
Heute haben wir zum ersten Mal
den Wetterbericht bekommen.
Wir hätten ihn
an den vorherigen Tagen
auch schon per SMS
auf das Satellitentelefon
geschickt bekommen sollen,
aber das hat nicht funktioniert.
Jetzt haben wir den ersten
Wetterbericht mündlich bekommen.
Jetzt mussten wir
eine Planänderung machen,
weil wir erfahren haben, dass
die nächsten zwei Tage gut sind.
Die fünf Tage danach
werden schlecht sein
mit Temperaturstürzen
und viel Niederschlag.
Wir haben uns dafür entschieden,
morgen nicht
zurück ins base camp zu gehen,
sondern zu versuchen,
morgen den Gipfel zu machen.
1'200 Höhenmeter in einem Tag?
Ein gewagter Entscheid.
Auf halbem Weg
wollen sie ein Biwak errichten,
das ihnen als Nachtlager dient, wenn
sie den Gipfel dann erreicht haben.
Die Jungs sind noch längst nicht
richtig akklimatisiert.
Aber - der Berg ruft und lockt,
und sie wollen endlich
ihren ersten unbestiegenen Gipfel
erobern.
5 Uhr morgens.
Das Expeditionsteam
hat einen strengen Tag vor sich -
und einen ersten Test,
was die Höhe mit ihnen anstellt.
* Schweres Atmen *
Und wieder
überrascht sie das Tian-Shan-Wetter.
Ein kleines Gewitter ist aufgezogen.
Es hat ein wenig Graupel.
Aber solange es nicht regnet,
wird man nicht wirklich nass,
von daher geht es.
Also immer Gemüse, gemütlich,
einen Fuss vor den anderen.
Ja, ja.
* Donner, Schrei *
Seht ihr jetzt?
Sturm, ihr Landratten!
* Klagender Klassik-Pop-Song:
"Requiem For A Tower" von Escala *
Noch 300 Höhenmeter
bis zum Deadman Peak.
Langsam macht sich
die dünne Luft bemerkbar -
wie alte Männer
stapfen die Jungs durch den Schnee
und kämpfen um jeden Meter.
Fühlt sich an wie auf dem Säntis!
Einfach
mit einem Strumpf über dem Kopf.
Wie geht's hinten?
- Geht nicht, keine Chance.
Hier kann man nicht durch.
- Riesenspalte?
Ja, 20 m Abbruch.
So ein Loch.
Und hoch darüber?
- Oder hier so?
Wie geht es mit dem Kopf?
Ich habe Kopfweh.
- Kopfweh? Trinken!
Hey, Denis!
Gratuliere! Danke dir!
Hoah!
Oh, Sebi!
- Gratuliere!
Bravo, Denis!
- Bravo, legends!
Bien joue!
- Sebastien, gratuliere!
Jetzt spüre ich die Höhe.
- Jetzt erst?
Ja, seit da unten.
Vorher ging es gut.
Ein bisschen Kopfweh habe ich.
Wegen der Sonne.
Hey!
- Hey!
Merci!
- Super, bravo!
Endlich haben sie geschafft,
wovon jeder Bergsteiger
sein Leben lang träumt:
auf einem Gipfel zu stehen,
der noch nie zuvor
von einem Menschen bezwungen wurde.
Es ist cool,
als Erster hier oben zu sein.
Aber die Traverse zeigt,
warum wir die Ersten waren:
Bis vor dem Gipfel ging es gut,
aber dann gab es viele Wechten,
es ist voll davon.
Und wir müssen
die Ostflanke wieder durchqueren,
zwischen Eis und Schnee,
der nicht hielt.
Ich bin froh, wenn ich wieder
unten an einem Ort bin,
wo wir diese Schwierigkeiten
los sind.
Denn hier auf 5'400 m
ist es echt krass.
Der schnelle Aufstieg
ist an keinem der jungen Bergsteiger
spurlos vorübergegangen.
Nach der kommenden Nacht im Biwak
werden sie noch so gerne
wieder zum base camp hinuntersteigen.
David weiss genau, was die Jungs
nach ihrer Rückkehr brauchen: Salz.
Salut! Hola! Ja!
Mmh!
Boah! Mmh!
* Entspannter Popsong: "Can't Get You
Out Of My Head" von Kylie Minogue"
Au, mein Kopf!
Ah!
So, zehn Jahre jünger.
Von 4'200, ohne akklimatisiert
zu sein auf dieser Höhe,
direkt auf 5'400,
ist eigentlich zu schnell.
Entsprechend haben auch einige der
Jungs die Höhe ein wenig gespürt,
gemerkt, was das bedeutet.
Das war sicher
eine wertvolle Erfahrung,
um die ganze Sache hier
realistisch einschätzen zu können.
... noch mal auf den Gipfel,
das hat mich fertiggemacht.
Als es dir mies ging,
was hast du genau gemerkt?
Kopfweh?
Ja, das hatte ich,
aber dann wurde es mir schlecht.
Wenn es einem schlecht ist und
man dann mal erbricht, macht es so.
Ich hatte bis auf den Gipfel
eigentlich kein Kopfweh.
Ich habe mich recht gut gefühlt.
Aber nachher unten im Camp
hatte ich ein paar Stunden Kopfweh.
Aber schon beim Einschlafen
war nichts mehr. Das war super.
Ich bin
v.a. auf dem Rücken eingeschlafen
und habe irgendwie
das Atmen vergessen.
Und auf einmal ...
* Schnelles Schnaufen *
... gemerkt,
dass ich eigentlich Luft brauche.
Das ist mir etwa 20-mal passiert.
Bis ich auf die Seite gelegen bin,
dann ist es nicht mehr passiert.
Das ist eigentlich normal.
Viele Leute machen ab einer gewissen
Höhe eine periodische Atmung.
Zwischendurch
macht man Atemaussetzer,
dann atmet man schneller,
dann hört man wieder auf.
Die einen waren mehr krank.
Sie haben viel gegeben.
Vielleicht gibt man einmal zu viel,
man denkt: "Jetzt geht es!"
Und dann war man zu schnell.
Man muss schon sparen.
Man muss sich sagen:
"Langsam, Pause."
Man muss sparen.
Es geht um das Leben.
Die Ärztin Nora Bienz kommt mit
einem Nachschub-Treck ins base camp,
um ihren Kollegen Roman Hari
abzulösen.
Beide betreuen die Expedition
ehrenamtlich.
Stabsübergabe der Höhenmediziner.
Augentropfen oder so
hast du nie gebraucht, oder?
Habe ich nie gebraucht, nein.
Den Sam-Splint habe ich mitgenommen.
Hast du einen dabei?
Nein, den habe ich nicht dabei.
- Dann nimm doch den.
Das ist das Dokument für den Fall,
dass jemand
nicht mehr ansprechbar wäre,
dass wir über medizinische
Interventionen verfügen dürften.
Das haben alle unterschrieben.
Bis auf dich.
Das habe ich auch noch ausgedruckt.
- Ich gebe es dir trotzdem.
Ich war nicht sicher.
Gib es mir trotzdem.
Gut!
Dann hoffen wir,
es gehe alles so gut wie bisher.
Der Xuelian Feng,
das nächste Ziel
nach der rund zweiwöchigen
Akklimatisationsphase,
überragt den Deadman Peak
noch einmal um mehr als 1'000 m.
Für seine Besteigung
muss das Expeditionsteam zuerst
einige Massnahmen für die Sicherheit
treffen.
Als Erstes wollen sie
einen Weg über den Gletscher
zwischen base camp und dem Fuss
des Xuelian Feng vorbereiten.
Mit seinen Spalten
und dem losen Geröll
ist dieses Gelände
nicht ungefährlich.
Zudem brauchen sie
ein gut ausgerüstetes Lager
auf der gegenüberliegenden Seite
des Gletschers,
in dem sie Material deponieren
und notfalls übernachten können.
Jetzt gilt es,
die Route zum Gipfel zu wählen.
Zum ersten Mal
in der bald dreijährigen Geschichte
des Expeditionsteams
gibt es Meinungsverschiedenheiten.
Das ist offen.
Das müssen wir uns noch überlegen.
Ich hätte generell
noch einen anderen Plan:
Wenn du beim Pfeiler links gehst,
bist du auch wieder recht hoch
und dort ist auch
eine markante, schwierige Stelle,
die auf ca. 5'500 ist.
Links durch die ganzen
Gletscherabbrüche hochzukraxeln,
dafür bin ich
ehrlich gesagt nicht motiviert.
Jeder sagt etwas anderes.
Wir sind eine Gruppe.
Es ist nur ein Vorschlag.
Genau. Diskutieren wir das.
Die Route da
ist irgendwie wie zwei Eiger.
Wir sind
die Höhe aber noch nicht gewohnt
mit dem,
was wir bisher gemacht haben.
Das ist alles vorbereitet.
Zum Akklimatisieren kannst du ja
unten schon Absatzstände reinmachen.
Du hast gesehen,
wie die Wand ist, wenn es schneit.
Ja, klar.
- Es schneit jeden Nachmittag.
Wie kommst du dann hinten runter,
wenn du hinten eine Linie machst?
Da musst du
gezwungenermassen auch abseilen.
Hinten ist nur zum Schauen, aber ja.
Ich habe Respekt vor dem Ding da.
- Das musst du, absolut.
Sagten wir nicht,
einfach irgendwie auf die Schulter,
und dann von der Schulter aus
beim Schneegrat hoch.
Das ist ja
mehr oder weniger ein Felsgrat.
Nein, ein Schneegrat. Hast du dir
die Bilder nicht angeschaut?
Doch.
- Auf der Südseite ist Schnee.
Ich denke jetzt -
vielleicht ändert sich das wieder -,
diese Route ist wie ein Traum.
Aber nicht mega realistisch.
Ohne Erfahrung.
- Mit dem Schneegrat oben?
Ich weiss, was du meinst.
Aber du verstehst scheinbar
die Länge nicht ganz.
Du erinnerst dich doch,
wie du da oben warst.
Es war nur eine Idee.
- Ja, Ideen sind gut.
Aber gute Ideen müssen auch
begründet und verteidigt werden.
Trotz dicker Luft hat sich das Team
auf eine gemeinsame Route geeinigt.
Die Vorarbeiten gehen weiter.
Wir gehen nachher mal
Richtung Gletscher
die ersten Stufen einrichten.
Mal schauen.
Die anderen kommen später,
richten für uns das ABC ein
und tragen die schweren Sachen
nach hinten.
Das Team will Fixseile
beim Einstieg der geplanten Route
zum Gipfel des Xuelian Feng
anbringen.
Sie sollen dazu dienen, die besonders
langwierige Einstiegspassage
rasch zu überwinden.
Nicolas hat nach wie vor
massive Bedenken
über die Machbarkeit der Route.
Irgendwie finde ich diesen Kessel
so etwas von unsympathisch.
Wenn du darüberschaust:
nur Abbrüche.
Am Mont Blanc
hast du vielleicht einen Abbruch,
hier hast du
irgendwie zehn über dir.
Und dann noch geladene Hänge.
Schau, sie sind wieder
genau auf den Lawinenkegeln.
Gestern ist bei diesem Abbruch
wieder etwas gekommen, also ...
Die Situation am Hang
ist mit Risiken behaftet,
die vom base camp aus
nicht erkennbar waren.
Ich glaube, es lohnt sich für uns
nicht wirklich, noch weiterzugehen.
Da kommt die ganze Zeit
recht viel Scheiss,
spin drift, Lawinen herunter.
Wir haben eh keine Fixseile mehr.
Wie sieht es bei euch oben aus?
Sie wollen nicht mehr weitergehen,
weil es für sie keinen Sinn macht,
weil immer wieder so spin drift
und Lawinen runterkommen.
* Beklemmende Klänge *
Am Schluss war es wirklich ...
war es gefährlich.
Da im Süden sind uns ziemlich
grosse Dinger auf den Kopf gefallen.
Die ursprünglichen Pläne
zur Begehung des Xuelian Feng
sind nicht durchführbar.
Aber der Rückschlag ist für das Ex-
peditionsteam kein Grund, aufzugeben.
Wir haben unser
ursprüngliches Projekt begraben.
Es wäre eine Erstbesteigung
auf über 6'000 m gewesen.
Aber wir haben
mehrere Lawinen gesehen.
Und es hatte Gletscherspalten
vor dem Couloir,
durch das wir hätten
klettern müssen, um hinaufzukommen.
Morgen soll es
nochmals schlechtes Wetter geben,
und ich hoffe,
dass es nachher möglich sein wird,
endlich die Expedition fortzuführen
und die grossen Monster
zu attackieren,
die seit zwei Wochen auf uns warten.
Das ist die 6'000er-Linie.
Und dann 6'250.
Das Team
hat einen neuen Plan gefasst:
Die Jungs werden sich aufteilen
und zwei verschiedene Gipfel angehen.
So können sie die unterschiedlichen
Wünsche und Fähigkeiten
von allen berücksichtigen.
Nicolas und Lukas
wollen den Xuelian West knacken.
Das Ziel von Nicu und mir
ist der Westgrat vom Xuelian West.
Auf ca. 4'000 m schlafen,
dann würden wir
in zwei bis drei Etappen
auf den Gipfel auf gut 6'500.
Die Nordwand hier
ist wirklich 2'500 m hoch,
schon sehr eindrücklich.
Deshalb brauchen wir auch
fünf Tage schönes Wetter,
um nichts zu riskieren.
Die Route des anderen Teams
ist nicht weniger ambitioniert.
Hier werden wir ein erstes Mal
schlafen, auf ca. 4'500,
dann auf dieser Plattform
noch einmal.
Von hier aus auf den Vorgipfel,
hinten noch mal hinab ins Joch
zwischen dem Hauptgipfel
und dem Vorgipfel,
das Materialdepot machen,
das wäre auf ca. 6'000 m.
Am nächsten Tag werden wir
versuchen, den Gipfel zu erreichen.
Dann hier durch das Couloir wieder
zurück ins ABC und ins base camp.
Der Wetterbericht
sagt fünf schöne Tage voraus.
Morgen früh soll es losgehen.
Ein Grund, den Schweizer Fondue-Käse
aus dem Gefrierschrank zu holen.
Es gibt Älplermagronen und
die Jungs übernehmen den Kochdienst.
Trockenfleisch
haben wir keines mehr, oder?
Können wir Nudeln haben?
Ja, hier habe ich welche.
Diejenigen, die ich immer koche?
Ja, dann kommt alles in eine Pfanne.
The cheese, the noodles ...
* Gemächliche Älplermusik *
Riecht gut!
Du musst probieren!
Das gibt dir Kraft für viele Monate.
Für ein gutes Gelingen
wird bis spät in die Nacht
dem bösen Geist des Tian-Shan-
Gebirges der Garaus gemacht.
Das ist der böse Rababou
mit dem Scheisswetter.
Böser Rababou! Böser Rababou!
Scheisswetter!
Ja, ist ein Cocktail.
Wenn er früh explodiert,
wird das Wetter schön.
Ich habe etwas Angst.
Yeah! Schönes Wetter!
Böser Rababou!
Heute ist es endlich so weit.
Die Schweizer wollen die Gipfel
der Bergkette Xuelian Feng
in Angriff nehmen.
Wie Fasnachtsküchlein.
- Ja, total.
Als Proviant für den ersten Tag
des Aufstiegs kocht David Gemüsereis.
Die beiden Seilschaften
machen sich bereit für den Abmarsch.
Die eine Gruppe um Expeditionsleiter
Denis will den Nordgipfel erreichen.
Heute Morgen ist eigentlich
ziemlich gutes Wetter.
Es sieht aus,
als könnte es nochmals etwas regnen.
Aber das ist
eigentlich nicht allzu böse.
Jetzt starten wir mal.
Nicolas und Lukas planen
die Erstbegehung des Xuelian West.
Nicu, ich habe ein Pack Reis, gell!
Wie?
- Ich habe ein Pack Reis.
Wir haben etwas weniger Stress
als die andere Seilschaft,
denn wir schlafen in der
ersten Nacht noch etwas tiefer.
Wir schlafen auf 4'000,
sie oben auf 4'500.
Und sie müssen evtl.
auch ziemlich spuren.
Von daher können wir es heute
etwas gemütlicher angehen.
Beide Gruppen
geben sich vier bis fünf Tage Zeit,
um ihr Ziel zu erreichen.
So lange soll das angekündigte
Schönwetterfenster andauern.
Also, viel Glück!
- Hey, tschüss!
Gutes Gelingen!
Keine Dummheiten!
Viel Glück!
- Danke!
Schöne Route!
- Viel Glück!
Um 12 Uhr gehe ich dann mal.
Expeditionsärztin Nora Bienz
bleibt im base camp
und wird mit dem Team
sporadisch über Funk Kontakt haben.
Verstehst du Walliserdeutsch?
Das
ist meine offizielle Funksprache.
* Erhabene Musik *
Der erste Tag ist für das Team West
vergleichsweise einfach.
Nicolas und Lukas
steigen heute nur 500 m hoch
und wollen
auf 4'000 m ü.M. übernachten.
Der nächste Tag
wird dafür umso strenger:
1'200 Höhenmeter an der steilen,
schnee- und eisbedeckten Westflanke
des Xuelian West stehen ihnen bevor.
* Langgezogener Pfiff *
Wir sind jetzt hier im Lager 1
unseres Xuelian West.
Jetzt sind wir direkt ...
... direkt unter der Nordwand.
Wir haben entschieden,
dass wir lieber mehr Essen haben
und weniger Sicherheit.
Nein, wir haben jetzt für vier Tage,
für drei bis vier Tage Essen dabei.
Ich glaube, z.T. liegt die Schärfe
an den Nudeln und nicht am Gewürz.
Das ist mega scharf!
* Entspannter Rap aus der Box:
"Traumreise" von Massive Töne *
Links von mir sind fünf Seracs,
rechts von mir
eine verdammte Geröllhalde.
Wieso sprichst du immer von dir?
Von uns!
Von uns, ja, Scheisse!
- Heilandsack!
Man sieht, wie egoistisch und
selbstverliebt ich wieder mal bin.
Aber ich liege ja rechts,
wenn Steinschlag ist.
Und links von mir
ist gleich eine Gletscherspalte.
Das ist ja nicht so schlimm.
Denn wir machen ja Extremalpinismus.
Merci.
Gell, Hönti?
- Ja.
# ... und morgen zeig ich dir
Londons schönste Ecken,
# Big Ben und die fetten Glocken ...
Ziemlich gut!
- Gell!
Team Nord hat sich
für den ersten Tag mehr vorgenommen.
Ihr erstes Biwak
errichten sie auf 4'600 m Höhe.
Alors!
Ich glaube, die anderen
sind da unten auf der Moräne,
beim Lawinenkegel.
Sebi, suchst du einen Toten?
Nein. Ich schaue dafür, dass wir
nicht tot sind in der Nacht.
* Lachen *
Der Biwak-Platz ist sicher -
es gibt keine Gletscherspalten
unter der Schneedecke.
Il y a encore un chapati.
- Oui! Un chapati.
Hallo! Habt ihr News vom Wetter?
(Nora)
Ja, der Wetterbericht tönt sehr gut.
Morgen soll es relativ stabil sein,
so wie heute.
Okay, tipptopp.
Sag einen Gruss!
- Einen Gruss von allen.
Einen Gruss von allen
und auch von Sebi spezielle Grüsse.
Vielen Dank!
Von der anderen Gruppe
habe ich schon gehört.
Team West geht es gut.
Okay, ganz gut.
Dann haben wir
den nächsten Termin ...
(Denis) ... morgen um 20 Uhr.
- ... morgen um 20 Uhr?
Ja, morgen um 20 Uhr, perfekt.
(Denis)
Sie soll ihn eingeschaltet lassen.
Du lässt den Funk eingeschaltet.
Selbstverständlich,
ist immer eingeschaltet.
Super, gute Nacht!
Schlaft gut!
Ja.
Schlafen Sie guten Tag.
Es ist heiss.
Morgen wird das Wetter bombastisch,
wie Nora sich ausdrückte.
Wir sind also bereit
zum Weitermachen.
Wir erwarten,
dass der Schnee morgen hart ist,
dass es gefriert.
Dann kommen wir
etwas besser vorwärts.
Heute sind wir bis zu den
Oberschenkeln eingesunken.
Wir geben uns hier gegenseitig warm.
Wir sind zu viert,
und das geht echt gut.
Sebi la.
Seb!
- Hey!
Et moi.
Morgendämmerung
am Westgrat des Xuelian Feng.
Ich habe etwas Kuhnagel.
Lukas und Nicolas brechen zum
zweiten Tag ihres Gipfelsturms auf.
1'200 Höhenmeter eis- und
schneeklettern liegen vor ihnen -
eine Tour de Force,
v.a. für Nicolas, der bereits
auf den Akklimatisationstouren
die Höhe schlecht vertragen hat.
Gut.
- Streng.
Ein Blick
zurück auf ihr Biwak beweist:
Sie haben gefährlich geschlafen -
und trotzdem richtig entschieden:
Die Lawine donnert
auf der gegenüberliegenden Seite
ihres Nachtlagers in den Talkessel.
Gell, Nicu,
wirklich nicht verheizen!
Was?
- Wirklich nicht verheizen.
Ich geh Gemüse.
- Ja.
Brr, hier zieht es wieder.
Im base camp hat Nora
einen überraschenden Gast:
Roman ist nach der ersten Nacht
am Berg zurückgekehrt,
weil ihm eine kleine Verletzung
die Weiterführung der Tour
vermasselt hat.
Das ist scheisse, was?
Im Moment ist es etwas schwierig,
herauszufinden,
was das Hauptproblem ist.
Einerseits ist es der Oberschenkel,
wo er einfach eine Entzündung hat,
bei der es schwer zu sagen ist,
woher sie wirklich kommt.
Wahrscheinlich hat sich einfach
durch die Reibung und das Schwitzen
ein Pickel oder
ein eingewachsenes Haar entzündet.
Das hat sich jetzt
ziemlich ausgedehnt.
Das konnte ich jetzt
rausschneiden, spülen und verbinden.
Ich glaube,
das ist jetzt wesentlich besser.
Er hat jetzt dazu noch ein cold pack
und hatte ein Schmerzmittel.
Neu fühlt er sich aber fiebrig,
hat Schüttelfrost
und ist recht schlapp.
Ich weiss es auch gerade nicht,
ob er sich einfach erkältet hat
oder ob es in Zusammenhang steht
mit dem Bein.
Hör mal: Das wäre ein Pretuval.
Was?
Ein Pretuval, also mit Dafalgan
und solchen Sachen drin.
Es ist jetzt ein Stück besser.
Als ich mich hingelegt habe ... Puh!
Nimm mal das.
Ich komme dann in einer Stunde
schauen, wie es dir geht,
kurz vor dem Essen. Ist gut?
- Ja, tipptopp, danke.
Sonst meldest du dich.
Im allerschlimmsten Fall kann das
mal eine Blutvergiftung geben.
So abgelegen
in einem base camp auf 3'500
ist man vielleicht
etwas vorsichtiger
und hat
ein etwas weniger gutes Bauchgefühl
als wenn das Gleiche
in der Stadt Bern passieren würde.
Die verbleibenden Mitglieder
der Seilschaft am Xuelian Nord
setzen den Aufstieg ohne Roman fort.
Wir sind nun im Couloir
auf über 4'900 m hochgestiegen.
Geht's, Denis?
Ja, gut gespurt!
Es ist steil, nicht?
Ja, ist eine grosse Wand.
Sicher 700 m.
Von unten sah es kürzer aus.
Ja, fast 4'900.
4'880.
Ja, wir haben es gleich.
Wir freuen uns,
wenn wir uns ausruhen können.
Das alles haben wir gemacht.
Jetzt sind wir langsam kaputt.
Endlich
das verdammte Couloir fertig.
War doch lang, was?
Ja,
etwas länger als wir dachten.
aber es waren auch viele Höhenmeter.
Voila, dort unten ist das base camp.
Das ist ganz und gar nicht schlecht.
Ist hoch, dieses Ding, nicht?
- Man spürt die Höhe.
Oui.
Dass einen so etwas
zum Abstieg zwingt, ist mega doof.
Man wünscht sich im ersten Moment,
dass einem lieber
ein Stein auf den Kopf fällt,
damit es wenigstens etwas ist,
das man sieht
und bei dem man merkt: logisch.
Aber negativ denken
ist schlecht investierte Energie.
Jetzt muss man die Sonne geniessen
können, dann geht das wieder gut.
Ich bin 21 und habe
noch das ganze Leben vor mir.
Auf meiner ersten Expedition
konnten wir schon
einen 5'000er erstbesteigen,
wir konnten 4'500er als Erste
machen, das ist schon genial.
Ich glaube, man muss es so sehen.
* Beklemmende Klänge *
Am Xuelian West
quälen sich Lukas und Nicolas
zu ihrem zweiten Biwak-Platz hoch.
Sie bekommen mit voller Wucht
zu spüren,
was es heisst,
in dieser Höhe unterwegs zu sein.
Streng, was?
5'500 ist schon
ganz klar oberhalb der Felsen.
* Beklemmende, schräge Töne *
Allez!
Hier haben wir gerade
tricky Felspassagen drin.
Der Fels
ist nicht so wahnsinnig geil.
Recht brüchig.
Wir schlafen da, das ist die ...
Draussen.
Das Team um Denis hat sich
einen speziell lauschigen Biwak-Platz
auf 5'600 m Höhe ausgesucht.
Wir sind gut organisiert.
Wir essen die Teller nicht leer,
wir schlafen am Tisch.
Das sind Zustände hier ...
Gute Nacht, bis morgen.
Kinder, sagt schön auf Wiedersehen!
- Bonne nuit!
Au revoir!
- Au revoir!
Für Lukas und Nicolas
ist der Tag noch nicht zu Ende.
Sie sind auf der Suche
nach einem Biwak-Platz für die Nacht.
Nicolas kann nicht mehr.
Ich möchte gerne
so niedrig wie möglich.
Diese verdammt Höhe!
Wir machen hier
ein 5-Stern-Biwak-Plätzchen.
Ich habe gemerkt, dass ich auf 5'500
fast nicht mehr pickeln mag.
Noch 550 m trennen Lukas und Nicolas
vom Gipfel des Xuelian West.
Sie hoffen, dass sie sich
über Nacht ein wenig erholen können.
* Beklemmende Klänge *
Ich bleibe morgen
wohl voraussichtlich hier.
Wieso kommst du
zu diesem Entschluss, aufzugeben?
Ich konnte seit über 30 Std.
nichts mehr essen.
Und besser wird es auf dieser Höhe
ganz sicher nicht.
Ich habe Kopfweh.
Ach Hönti!
Oh!
Oh, Nicu, du tust mir mega leid.
Ah!
Es wäre verdammt schade,
wenn du hier abbrechen würdest.
Du hättest die Möglichkeit,
dennoch raufzugehen.
Es gibt Schlimmeres.
Entweder alle oder keiner.
Nein, nein,
nimm nicht Rücksicht auf mich!
Es kann doch nicht sein,
dass hier Endstation ist.
Aber wir sind ein Team.
Und keine ...
... Einzelkämpfer.
Ach, stell dir vor!
Ich könnte doch kein bisschen wütend
auf dich sein, nur weil du sagst ...
Weil wir nicht weiterkönnen,
weil es dir nicht gut geht.
Nein, also Nicu!
- Du musst nicht wütend sein.
Nein, aber wenn ich entscheide,
dass ich mir dir runterkomme,
ist es so.
Dann bin ich weder enttäuscht
noch sonst irgendwas.
Du musst überhaupt kein
schlechtes Gewissen haben.
Das ist einfach so.
- Ich habe kein schlechtes Gewissen.
Aber es ist deine Entscheidung.
Ah, ich bin schlecht
in solchen Sachen, Nicu,
alleine Dinge zu entscheiden.
Kommen jetzt deine weiblichen Gene
zum Vorschein, oder was?
* Räuspern *
(Funkgerät) One.
Lukas an Roman, antworten!
Ciao, Roman! Wie geht es dir?
Ja,
eigentlich schon wieder recht gut.
Also, Roman, wir haben gemeinsam
entschieden, morgen abzusteigen.
Okay. Schade, das zu hören.
Gute Nacht
und passt auf beim Abstieg!
Okay, gut, vielen Dank!
In dem Fall bis morgen vielleicht!
Die beiden jungen Bergsteiger
haben ihr Ziel nicht erreicht.
Aber sie haben erfahren,
dass Freundschaft
ebenso erfüllend sein kann
wie das Erstürmen eines Gipfels.
Die Seilschaft am Xuelian Nord.
Es ist bereits Abend
und aussergewöhnlich spät,
um noch am Berg unterwegs zu sein.
Sebastien, Denis und Sebastian
kämpfen immer noch - um jeden Meter.
Uah!
* Melancholische Musik *
* Triumphale Klänge *
* Jubel *
Um 22 Uhr stehen die Bergsteiger
auf dem Gipfel.
Gerade rechtzeitig,
um Zeugen des wohl schönsten
Sonnenuntergangs ihres Lebens
zu werden.
* Feine Klaviermusik *
Hey!
- Sali!
So!
Hey, Roman!
- Nicu!
Hey, schade, was?
Habt ihr es auch geschafft?
- Ja.
Ja, Scheisse!
Beim Abstieg ging es,
aber die letzten zwei, drei Tage
konnte ich
fast nichts mehr trinken oder essen.
Für Lukas fand ich es
einfach nur schade,
dass er quasi wegen mir
nicht auf den Gipfel konnte.
Aber im Grunde genommen
ist man halt ein Team.
Es gehört halt einfach dazu:
Wenn es einem schlecht geht,
hängt man halt am gleichen Seil.
Man muss einfach zusammenarbeiten.
Wir merkten:
Hier geht es wieder in eine Spalte.
Es ging einfach ins Bodenlose.
- Super.
Man konnte Zeug reintun - nichts.
Nachts hörte man plötzlich: wumm!
Sicher bin ich
ein Stück weit recht enttäuscht.
Aber man muss es so sehen:
Wir durften hierherkommen
und wir durften versuchen,
auf diesen Berg zu kommen.
Deshalb ist auch das Absteigen
wieder ein Dürfen und kein Müssen.
Das waren die drei Tage,
an denen wir die Chance hatten,
auf den Gipfel zu kommen.
In den Alpen ist es auch so:
Man kann nicht jeden Berg
beim ersten Angriff besteigen.
Das gehört zum Bergsteigen dazu.
Und es ist für Nicu und mich
auch eine sehr grosse
und lehrreiche Erfahrung
mit der Höhe und miteinander
und wie wir in der Höhe reagieren.
Es gab den Moment, als wir
oben im Lager waren auf 5'700,
es war gegen 22 Uhr
und ich schaue
den Reissverschluss des Zelts an.
Ich schaue und studiere haargenau,
wie ich ihn ziehen muss,
damit er aufgeht.
Plötzlich merke ich:
Oh, oh, es geht nichts mehr.
Ich öffne den Reissverschluss,
halte den Kopf aus dem Zelt,
muss erbrechen.
Dann schaue ich herum und sehe
den schönsten Sonnenuntergang.
Dann bist du einfach dort:
Oh, wow!
Zum Glück musste ich erbrechen,
sonst hätte ich das nicht gesehen.
Salut!
- Hey!
* Lachen *
Gratuliere!
Super! Lebendig, gesund.
Hey, Denis, bravo!
Gratuliere!
- Merci!
Sind alle gesund?
- Ja.
Einmal mehr hat es sich bestätigt:
Es ist der Kopf,
der die letzte Meile geht.
Mein Team war supermotiviert.
Sie hatten entschieden,
den Gipfel zu machen,
aber die letzten 500 m haben sie
wirklich mit sich gekämpft.
Ich habe mich
in dieser Nacht übergeben.
Dann noch ein paar Mal tagsüber
und am Fuss der Wand.
Ich habe ihnen dann gesagt, dass ich
zu schwach sei und es nicht schaffe.
Und sie haben gesagt:
"Wenn du motiviert bist, dann gehen
wir rauf. Wir werden alles spuren."
Und so gingen sie voraus
und ich folgte in meinem Tempo.
Sie haben das super gemacht.
Am Ende war es wirklich nur noch
der Kopf, der sie voranbrachte.
Es war sicher immer streng, auch
die letzten Meter auf den Gipfel.
Aber wir wurden belohnt.
Wir kamen beim letzten Tageslicht
auf dem Gipfel an.
Die Stimmung war wunderschön.
Alles war rot, alles hat geleuchtet.
Perfektes Wetter,
eine Riesenaussicht.
Das entschädigt eigentlich
für alles.
Nun freue ich mich aufs Heimgehen.
Ich freue mich,
meine Familie zu sehen,
Schweizer Sachen zu essen:
Schokolade, Käse, Brot.
Am meisten vermisst
habe ich natürlich meine Freundin.
Ca, c'est clair.
Sie haben toll gekämpft,
und das in ihrem Alter. Hut ab!
Denn das
ist normalerweise ein Alter,
in dem man zwar
physisch sehr stark ist,
aber eben nicht mental
und in der Ausdauer.
Ich bin wirklich stolz auf sie.
Nach sechs langen Wochen
ist das Abenteuer zu Ende.
Es war ein langer Weg,
auf den sich das Expeditionsteam
vor drei Jahren gemacht hat.
* Melodiöser Pop-Rock Song: "A Head
Full Of Dreams" von Coldplay *
# Oh I think I landed
where there are miracles at work.
# For the first and for the hunger
come the conference of birds.
# A head full of dreams.
# Into life I've just been spoken
# with a head full,
a head full of dreams.
# A head full of dreams.
# Into life I've just been spoken
# with a head full,
a head full of dreams.
Für die jungen Bergsteiger
und ihren lead guide
wird es nicht
das letzte Abenteuer sein.
Sie werden wieder aufbrechen,
gemeinsam oder mit anderen Freunden,
die ihre Leidenschaft teilen.
Aber immer werden sie
die Bilder, die Gefühle,
die Momente der Gefahren
und der Erfolge,
die sie im Tian-Shan-Gebirge
erlebt haben, mit sich tragen.